hey 42 here North Korea Iran Syria
Russia and Ukraine China India and
Pakistan these are a list of the most
pressing flash points of the last year
when political economic or social
tensions reach boiling points in an area
that region is declared a flashpoint by
various states this means it has the
potential to erupt into war or another
kind of disaster it seems that every six
months or so yet another flashpoint is
added to the exhaustive global watch
list and of course the most devastating
way any of these flashes can go bang is
by descending into nuclear war it's
likely that America would either be the
instigator or recipient of that first
nuclear blow given its position how's
the big daddy defender of Western
democracy but even if it doesn't
instigate a nuclear strike as soon as it
happens elsewhere in the world you can
be fairly certain that the good old USA
is going to get involved fairly quickly
this makes the nuclear football the most
important briefcase in the world this
one piece of apparel could quite
literally decide the future of humanity
but it's shrouded in so much secrecy so
how does a nuclear football work and how
exactly do a briefcase and a biscuit
launch a nuclear weapon whenever you see
the President of the United States away
from the White House whether he be
visiting peach farmers in Georgia or
attending a banquet at Buckingham Palace
you will always notice something
following him more specifically someone
carrying something wherever he travels
he must always be accompanied by an
aide-de-camp a senior assistant to the
president who has passed the most
stringent of all background security
checks
a process codenamed Yankee white this
aid will always be carrying a mysterious
black briefcase and he will guard it
with his life whilst on duty he is not
permitted to ever let it leave his sight
in fact it is literally tied to the aged
wrists and if the president goes for a
run his aide must jog behind him
briefcase in hand it must always be kept
on the same elevator the president is on
and in the same helicopter it is named
the football after a Cold War nuclear
attack plan that was codenamed dropkick
this is no ordinary briefcase the entire
thing weighs a hefty 20 kilograms inside
the black leather outer sits a pink
reinforced aluminium case manufactured
by an American Japanese firm zero
Halliburton their cases are known for
being tough and water and dust tight
which is really important because you
wouldn't want to spilt a cup of coffee
leaking inside in this particular
briefcase and interfering with the
critical electronics and documents but
what is inside it you ask there are four
items in the football everything the
president would need to coordinate in
order the launch of a nuclear warhead
the first item is a black book
containing every option available to the
US military these plans cover all bases
from launching a small tactical
preemptive strike all the way to a
full-on nuclear Armageddon obviously
what these plans are is highly
classified but each one is intricately
detailed inside the black book giving
the commander-in-chief the information
such as expected casualties likely
repercussions timings etc that he needs
to make the optimal decision although
Jimmy Carter thought that the plan was
so complex that he asked for a much
simplified summary of each to be added
to the book these dumbed down versions
are reportedly little more than cartoon
sketches and one-line descriptions of a
sources say that the simplified version
is laid
like a Denny's breakfast menu and the
president simply has to choose a
selection of items from two columns to
arrive at a customized plan of attack
the second item is a book listing all
the classified locations of the US
military installations as well as
bunkers and other safe places where the
president can be taken in case of an
emergency the third item is a manila
folder with ten pages describing how to
use the emergency broadcast system
established in 1997 this allows the
President to directly address every US
citizen at the same time via TV channels
radio and mobile phone communications it
is often used to warn citizens of
tornadoes and flash floods in affected
areas but it would of course be used to
address the entire nation in the event
of a nuclear attack the fourth and final
thing inside the briefcase is the most
important of all the biskits no it's not
in case the president wants a quick
snack whilst unleashing a nuclear
Armageddon upon the world the biscuit is
a credit card sized laminated card that
simply has a vertical column of codes
printed on it these are known as the
gold codes and are essentially the
president's password to enable him and
only him to launch nuclear weapons in
reality they are not a password to say
but a way for the president to without
any question of doubt identify himself
as the president when he contacts the
Joint Chiefs of Staff to give the order
to strike but more on us in a minute it
could quite literally be the end of the
world of these codes fell into the wrong
hands
so there are naturally some prudent
security measures in place according to
some sources the codes are changed every
single day apparently the NSA generates
a unique set of random codes daily and
distributes them to the only four
recipients that will need them in the
case of a nuclear attack the White House
the Pentagon US Strategic Command and
tacamo or take charge and move out
this last one is a growing East six
mercury constantly in flight it acts as
an airborne relay station to take the
president's attack commands and
distribute them over encrypted airwaves
to military installations all around the
US in seconds it is in place just in
case an enemy nuclear strike takes out
all the land-based broadcast stations a
new biscuit is created for the
president's every day with that day's
unique Gold POTUS as an additional
security step there are more codes
printed on the biscuit than are needed
most of the codes are decoys only after
inauguration is the president taught
precisely where the real codes are
located on the card and which ones to
ignore this is so if the biscuit is
physically stolen from the presidents
the thief would be unable to use it
because he would have no idea which of
the codes are real and which are fake a
simple yet elegant solution in 2000
during the Clinton administration bills
aid lost the biscuit and didn't tell
anyone for almost three months back then
the codes are only change once every
four months were still officials
repeatedly ask the aide if he had the
codes which is done regularly just to
make sure and each time he said
something along the lines of yeah sure
they're right here in this briefcase
when in reality he knew they were not
and had no idea where they were it's
been suspected but never confirmed by
insiders that it was actually Bill
Clinton himself who lost a biscuit and
his aide was just covering up for him
but it's not the only time the biscuit
has gone awry 39 President Jimmy Carter
infamously lost his when his suit was
sent to the dry cleaners of the biscuits
still in the jacket pocket after Reagan
was shot during an attempted
assassination in 1981 the hospital staff
in a panic to save his life stripped all
of his clothes and belongings and threw
them into a plastic bag which was shoved
into a corner and left there
the biscuit was later found to be in
that plastic bag but how do the football
and the biscuit actually work what would
the president have to do if he decided
to blow up his least-favorite
despot well first start I'm sorry to say
there is no actual nuclear button
presidents have historically said that
they have their finger on the button as
a scare tactic and a powerful
campaigning message because let's face
it it sounds much more threatening now
I've got a briefcase and a credit card
and I'm not afraid to use them the
finger on the button analogy is so
powerful that it has also been used as a
political attack tool why do you think
Hillary kept on espousing lines such as
Trump shouldn't have his finger on the
button because it makes him sound like a
mad man with his finger literally
hovering above a button all day and if
he doesn't get his KFC on time he might
just press it when the reality is
completely different as we will now
discover it's not quite as simple or
easy as that and there are of course
some safeguards in place sooner if the
president decides he would like to
annihilate a city or two this is exactly
what he is trained to do he notifies the
aid of his destructive desires and he is
quickly taken to the nearest private
room the football is opened up and the
biscuit is broken it is encased in a
plastic cover which the president wasn't
break open to see the codes the
president would then consult the black
book to decide on which plan of attack
he would like the football itself
however is not just a glorified
briefcase it contains a reliable
long-wave communication gear hence the
two aerials that can be seen protruding
from the top this very low-frequency
radio equipment has a direct and secure
link to the National Military Command
Center inside the Pentagon this allows
the president to phone the Joint Chiefs
of Staff from anywhere the
he can't if he chooses consults the
Joint Chiefs of Staff or any other
advisors he chooses for that matter to
get their opinion on his plan of attack
who may suggest an alternative approach
or to scale it up or down they may even
choose to resign on the spot as a former
protest against the president's
impending plan but it doesn't matter
because the final decision to launch
nuclear weapons and exactly how and how
many is ultimately the president's call
and nobody else's the Pentagon must
respect and carry out whatever he
instructs once a plan has been settled
on an officer in the Pentagon war room
sends the president a challenge code
this may be something along the lines of
Oscar Bravo there is only one correct
response to this challenge and it is the
gold code printed on a certain location
on the biskits known to the presidents
as we discussed earlier the president
then uses the football to send the
correct code back to the war room if the
war room is satisfied that they have
received the correct response and are
indeed receiving orders from the
President and no one else they prepare
an encrypted message this message is the
length of a tweet and includes
authentication codes needed to launch
the missiles and details of the attack
including the targets or targets the
severity and the time to launch this
secure message is broadcast throughout
the chain of command and this chain
begins with the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of staff's passes through
Strategic Command and ends with the
military personnel in the appropriate
ICBM silos on nuclear submarines whose
job it actually is to launch the
missiles the staff here will open a safe
that contains a card with the nuclear
authentication codes on which is
essentially a password to unlock the
launch system the safe code is compared
to the one broadcast by the Pentagon and
only if it matches will they proceed
with the launch the code is entered into
the computer and then the final failsafe
is
initiated the Tukey's system this is a
simple yet robust system that ensures no
single rogue soldier can launch a
missile by himself
there are five crew members on board
each nuclear submarine and inside each
underground silo each person has their
own unique key to launch the missile
they all insert their keys into separate
pre designated key holes in the computer
system but only two of the five keys are
needed to initiate a launch so even if
three crew members refuse to insert
their keys the launch will still go
ahead
but not if four refused to do so on top
of this there is one final failsafe the
missile will only launch if two keys are
inserted at the exact same time turned
and held there for at least five seconds
the key holes are spring loaded so
failing to hold the key in place will
abort the launch however the key holes
are sufficiently spaced apart so that
one person with both arms outstretched
cannot insert and turn two keys at the
same time and of a simple yet elegant
solution and that's it the missile will
now begin its trajectory towards its
program targets from the moment the
president first opens the nuclear
football
it will now be anywhere from two to five
minutes in the future that is how
quickly this rigorously practiced
routine would play out in real life
once those two keys are turned and the
missile is launched there is no going
back there is no system in place for the
president to change his mind mid-flight
World War II will have just begun and
most likely the end of humanity as we
know it but until that happens it would
be wise to make sure your personal
security is as strong as the president's
by using dashlane who have kindly
sponsored today's video the best way to
protect yourself
against hackers spammers and over online
friends is by using the leading password
manager and all-in-one security suite in
the sling he will store all of your
passwords in a super safe way without
ever having access to them or allowing
anyone but you to view them - Len
creates a strong and unique password for
all of your online account and also
fills them so you never have to click
forgot password ever again
and you don't have to sweat about the
extremely rare chance that - line could
be breached because - lanes safely
stores and decrypt your data on your
local device only using your master
password
this means that that's Lane never has
access to your personal data and then he
hacker would only see random noise -
Lane also autofills your credit card
information whilst online shopping so
you can make purchases without even
having to fetch your wallet - Lane has a
built-in VPN to encrypt your data and
keep your online activity anonymous best
of all it works on any device whether
you're protecting classified state
secrets or classified videos of your
cats there is no better way to make your
online world as safe as a nuclear bunker
and by using - Lee - Lane goes the extra
mile by alerting you of any of your
accounts or data are breached it also
has a dark web monitoring system that
will immediately let you know if your
personal information appears on the dark
web where it can be seen by hackers or
spammers for my experience - Lane is the
best all bases covered security and
time-saving tool out there and if you
visit my unique promo link in the
description you can get a free premium
child of - Lane for 30 days plus if you
enter 42 bit checkout you will get 10%
of dust Lane premium thanks for watching
and thanks again to dust Lane for
sponsoring this video don't forget to
check them out using the link below